good afternoon last night in Brussels I
set out Britain's new settlement with
the European Union this morning I've
just chaired a meeting of the cabinet in
which I updated them on the special
status we have secured for Britain and
the Cabinet agreed that the government's
position will be to recommend that
Britain remains in a reformed European
Union now I want to speak directly to
the British people to explain why we are
approaching one of the biggest decisions
this country will face in our lifetimes
whether to remain in a reformed European
Union or to leave the choice goes to the
heart of the kind of country we want to
be and the future that we want for our
children this is about how we trade with
neighboring countries to create jobs
prosperity and financial security for
our families and it's about how we
cooperate to keep our people safe and
our country strong I know there will be
many passionate arguments over the
months ahead and individual cabinet
ministers will have the freedom to
campaign in a personal capacity as they
wish but my responsibility as Prime
Minister is to speak plainly about what
I believe is right for our country I do
not love Brussels
I love Britain I'm the first to say that
there are still many ways in which
Europe needs to improve and that the
task of reforming Europe does not end
with yesterday's agreement and I will
never say that our country couldn't
survive outside Europe we are Great
Britain we can achieve great things that
is not the question in this referendum
the question is will we be safer
stronger and better off working together
in a reformed Europe or out on our own I
believe we'll be safer in a reformed
Europe because we can work with our
European partners to fight cross-border
crime and terrorism
I believe Britain will be stronger in a
reformed Europe because we can play a
leading role in one
world's largest organizations from
within helping to make the big decisions
on trade and security that determine our
future and I believe we'll be better off
in a reformed Europe because British
businesses will have full access to the
free trade single market bringing jobs
investment and lower prices let me be
clear
leaving Europe would threaten our
economic and our national security those
who want to leave Europe cannot tell you
if British businesses would be able to
access Europe's free trade single market
or if working people's jobs are safe or
how much prices would rise all they're
offering is a risk at a time of
uncertainty a leap in the dark our plan
for Europe gives us the best of both
worlds it underlines our special status
through which families across Britain
get all the benefits of being in the
European Union including more jobs low
prices and greater security but our
special status also means we're out of
those parts of Europe that do not work
for us so we will never join the euro
we will never be part of eurozone
bailouts never be part of the passport
free no borders area or a European army
or EU super state three years ago I
committed to the British people that I
would renegotiate our position in the
European Union and hold an in/out
referendum now I am delivering on that
commitment you will decide and whatever
your decision I will do my best to
deliver it on Monday I will commence the
process set out under our referendum Act
and I will go to Parliament and propose
that the British people decide our
future in Europe through an inert
referendum on Thursday the 23rd of June
the choice is in your hands but my
recommendation is clear I believe that
Britain will be safer stronger
and better off in a reformed European
Union thank you very much